un père
vert le plus pervers
qui le fait pas bon tomber entre les
griffes des deux imper de descente de
police alors victimes vous le verrez
s'en rendra compte très vite cette
semaine c'est Karen Cheryl disque d'or
dans une bonne douzaine de pays Karen
Cheryl présentatrice vedette sur TF1 qui
reçoit la visite de nos deux impairs
Fouettard
[Musique]
la poupe
radio si vous voulez aussi
je m'appelle Karen cherylan
de clown ridicule là
je vous ai dit que j'avais une
imagination absolument débridée
pas partie du cercle des intimes alors
ton nom de famille
je m'appelle Isabelle Morizet
non en plus il a un problème de
prononciation dites moi votre petit
copain pour les interrogatoires ça doit
pas être pratique
gros bébé et puis Lolita
et puis
des lunettes
et puis et puis qu'est-ce que vous
voulez mais le vrai surnom le vrai
surnom le vrai surnom j'ai pas envie de
vous le dire c'est quoi vulgaire
par une très belle après-midi d'été il y
a de cela dans une ville sublime avec
monument
27 ans pas plus non
[Musique]
vos talonnettes
mensuration mensuration idéale
tes yeux mon verre
sur les yeux merci du compliment non
numéro 12
je dois beaucoup à ma mère je la
remercie d'ailleurs
ou pas
tous les printemps
quand tu seras vieille qui continueras à
faire des chansons comme ça ou non tu
arrêteras quand tu auras des risques
ou pas
quelque chose
[Musique]
je tiendrai du dinosaure c'est à dire
fier de mérite et l'expérience de la vie
et vous nourrissait c'est-à-dire qu'il
était agriculteur
[Musique]
S
un tout petit verre de très bon vin
exceptionnellement pour accompagner un
très bon dîner
drive c'est ce que c'est Martini Drive à
mon avis vous savez pas c'est pour ça
qu'on te demande
alors à part ça est-ce que tu as déjà
fumé des pétards non quel jour
[Musique]
je suis naturellement bien éclaté dans
ma tête
très très bien
alors tu en as jamais fumé quoi tu
préfères prendre de la cocaïne dans les
studios tu as bien la cocaïne dans les
studios de la coca je m'amuse pas du
tout quand tu as chopé tout à l'heure en
bas là de la cocaïne
erreur c'était une boîte de poudre Caron
pour
à vous ouais
je suis une petite française extrêmement
fidèle à toutes les traditions civiques
quand même
j'ai des convictions politiques elle a
des convictions politiques genre dont je
ne parlerai pas avec vous
le premier coup de foudre
[Musique]
c'était en fait
un amour tout ce qu'il y avait depuis
pur et un amour d'enfant
dans ma tête
beaucoup plus tard
c'est à dire avant 20 ans
avant 20 ans combien d'années avant 20
ans
très peu d'années avant 20 ans très peu
18 17
18 ans tu as commencé à coucher avec des
garçons à 18h
[Musique]
porter le bout des doigts
bah non on enlève les feuilles ça donne
quoi ça donne quoi c'est un
questionnaire
non écoute euh
violent
ils montent quand même fait saigner je
réclame un gros plan sur le doigt ils
m'ont fait saigner
quand même est-ce que tu sais ce que
c'est que le point G
et bien moi j'ai envie de vous répondre
que le point G c'est le centre de
gravité c'est grave comme réponse très
grave tu es plutôt vaginal ou
titoridienne comme fille
moi je trouve plutôt abruti quand on est
fini de fermer on sait ce qu'on fait de
son blé en général
un volontaire courage
bravo et merci à Karen Cheryl d'avoir
joué tout d'avoir
cette descente de police le retour des
deux impairs lors d'une prochaine rafle
[Musique]
un peu mastoc
l'intervèrent le plus pervers
maintenant dans ta page nocturne c'est
une séquence noire qui traverse vos
téléviseurs vous connaissez le principe
les deux impairs de l'émission mettent
le grappin chaque semaine sur une star
une personnalité dans le but de lui
tirer ce qu'on appelle les vers du nez
dans la cage au volailles c'est Jeanne
Mas qu'on a embarqué
merci
c'est quoi ton nom à toi
masse
comme quoi
ça vient d'origine espagnole française
de nationalité residente en Italie
et le poids le poids ça dépend ça dépend
ce que j'enfile
jamais mais je dois peser entre 50 et 50
de kilos
et les dents alors devant c'est bien
mais
devant
parce que devant
ils sont commentés je veux là ils sont
gras secs
non non
ça dépend des fois tous les jours tous
les jours bah oui parce que ça dépend
alors quand je veux devenir brun il faut
bien que je me fasse une teint tout je
change une fois j'ai fait encore pire
c'est tout noir
j'ai tout enlevé bon quand tu seras plus
vieille tu feras quoi pour changer un
peu que tu feras du lifting tu feras des
implants de cheveux tu feras quoi du
lifting pourquoi pas tu es d'accord pour
un lifting
particulière
toujours
non non non ça m'arrive juste
en fait tu veux vraiment savoir c'est
quand je vais avoir mes règles
et puis on est là
voilà
une périphrase qu'est-ce que c'est une
périphrase je sais pas si tu sais ce que
c'est non français c'est pas espagnol je
sais pas expliquez-moi
plus simple un style logisme c'est quoi
ça c'est facile si logique
mais non non pas du tout
un tropisme
c'est quoi ça c'est déjà plus facile ah
tu sais ce que c'est
un truc de fille ah bon entre autres
mais je voudrais que vous m'expliquiez
tout ça
qui ne peuvent faire l'amour qu'avec des
vieillards
comment toi ça dépend
à côté de moi je mets un pyjama
tu préfères l'herbe le shit et lequel tu
préfères le marocain ou bien le noir à
côté
c'est alors là c'est dément c'est dément
c'est démenti rigoles c'est pas possible
je sais pas moi mon blog
en France
de dépenser de l'argent pour ça on me
l'offre j'ai des amis qui m'ont offrent
et je trouve ça très gentil
[Musique]
j'ai pas besoin de quoi
[Applaudissements]
ma cigarette comme ça
entre je sais pas Le Pen et marchait par
exemple
est-ce que c'est pas très loin où est-ce
que c'est vrai c'est différent ou très
différent le seul problème là-dedans
c'est que pour moi
c'est pas un problème tu vois j'arrive
très bien à vivre sans ces gens-là
je sais pas marcher par exemple tu t'en
foutrais autant que ce genre de vie
tu pourrais plus lire les journaux que
tu veux c'est pas grave tu peux me
répondre que tu dis pas le journal bravo
c'est des gens comme toi qu'ils arrivent
à Paris ça te dérange pas non plus
il y aura peut-être juste un problème de
langage tu vois c'est juste le problème
de langage
des disques tu t'en fous ça veut dire
que tu aurais chanté
avec les raisonnements comme ça
s'appelle le KGB mais c'est la même
chose
bah écoute si on me demande
les gens sont toujours les gens le
peuple et le pape de l'humanité toi je
chanterai je chanterai pour le peuple je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas ce genre de
principe que ce soit faite de l'humanité
ou la fête d'autres choses tu vois au
contraire la fête bleu blanc rouge de Le
Pen mais oui elles viennent de le dire
en ce moment bonne blague
en ce moment je suis avec personne
disons personne parce que j'en ai
plusieurs en même temps tu comprends vu
que je divise ma vie entre la France et
l'Italie je suis forcée d'en avoir plus
d'un
petit ami en France
au Canada j'en fais aussi dans le reste
de l'Europe donc tu comprends
Alberto comment tu le sais
ils appellent Alberto
oui il s'appelle Alberto il travaille
dans la mode
écoute jusqu'à présent ça va ils s'en
sort bien
il ne fait qu'une seule chose il est
hété par derrière c'est pas grave
mais dis donc tu es plutôt le sentiment
d'être clitoridienne ou vaginal comme
fille
je pense toutes les deux tous les deux
ouais ça dépend tu vois je veux dire
c'est pas que ça me dégoûte c'est que ça
me dégoûte oui peut-être que ça me
dégoûte on sait jamais proposé bien sûr
qu'on l'a proposé
non parce que je trouve que j'ai autre
chose à proposer
on a fait le tour de tout après au bout
d'un moment
qu'est-ce que tu as eu déjà des
expériences homosexuels
plutôt une dizaine une centaine une
cinquantaine
oui j'aurais peut-être besoin de vous
mettre quand même
en gros tu as tenu combien de garçons tu
penses combien de garçons peut-être une
cinquantaine c'est tout garçon
c'est important la taille du sexe de
l'homme vu que je pense également tu
vois que les hommes
je pense que les hommes ne savent pas
utiliser leur sexe tu sais je parle
également donc lorsqu'il est plus
puissant que un don qui est tout mignon
comme ça je veux dire il y a moins de
problèmes
et moins de problèmes quand c'est gros
oui
pendant un mois avec un homme lequel tu
préfères de tous les hommes qui assurent
tu peux choisir Gorbatchev puisque c'est
ton copain
Richard mais un français
un Français tu veux absolument
Christophe Lambert Christophe
c'est ainsi que sa chef descente de
police merci à Jeanne Mas d'avoir joué
le jeu
un peu mystique le plus mastoc
un pervers le plus pervers et après
qu'il est deux impaires Courtil
aujourd'hui le nom de la prochaine
victime Yves Simon chanteur écrivain
journaliste tout ça tout le monde le
sait ce n'est pas suffisant pour les
deux impairs il faut aller chez lui
histoire de voir et finalement un
domicile c'est quand même le meilleur
endroit pour cueillir un suspect
voilà
on va regarder ce qu'il y a dedans
[Musique]
ils y vont dans l'enveloppe l'indice
l'adresse de la plante d'Yves Simon un
hôtel de la rive gauche
voilà
ça va feignasse
Simon Simon ça vient d'où ça ça vient de
l'est de la France et du un peu plus au
sud aussi
mon père était acrobate
joyeux mariage
pour me nourrir ma mère et moi Napoléon
faucher beaucoup tu es pas hyper allez
alors prénom il va il va et après
Maurice Marcel Maurice Maurice Simon
52 quoi
mon imagination on s'en fout c'est des
conneries des trucs d'artistes ton
visage par exemple parle de toi
pas mal plutôt
on me dit souvent tu as de beaux yeux
dans ta tronche ce serait quoi ton
visage tu coupes là qu'est-ce que tu
peux
changerait le nez la bouche
et puis la bouche comme de long
j'aimerais bien verser
un peu de culture quand même oh un peu
oui
monanisme que ça veut dire panamanisme
ça doit être se branler je crois
scientifiquement pardon la truisme c'est
quoi un truc c'est répéter la même chose
une forme
une litote qu'est-ce que c'est assez
évité de dire le mot ou la l'idée
non c'est moi qui me jette sur elle la
vitrocard c'est toi qui jette sur elle
veut jamais mais c'est moi
aussi j'ai tendance à me jeter
tu continues avec elle tu es toujours
avec elle
pas du tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est rigoler non non pas du tout
alors puisque cette fille tous les jours
pendant deux mois c'est tout non
toutes les soirs
et c'était quoi alors qu'est-ce que tu
prenais tu sais ce que tu fumais
la meilleure tu connais bien alors je
connais très bien mais depuis tu as pu
fumer un joint
ça le fait planer un peu pas plané c'est
pas le mot c'est pire
allez allez
non ça me fait Évian un peu style
au-dessus des montagnes alors la
politique maintenant oui tu as voté pour
qui entre
pour l'actuel président
avec marchais ou Le Pen Nil qui fait 20
mètres carrés lequel tu choisis c'est le
Radeau de la Méduse
avec toi
n'importe quelle île de tous les trois à
poil dans l'île déserte tous les deux ok
tu veux être avec marcher le penche les
[ __ ] tous les deux on me dit de
choisir un des deux de choisir l'argent
lequel lequel il faut savoir lequel qui
va accepter
t'en fais pas pour lui
ah les ordures allez est-ce que alors
maintenant te demander
la tu as déjà eu des rapports
homosexuels
quand tu étais petit on te demande à
choisir 12 ans 8 ans quand les petits
garçons comme tout le monde avait des
expériences homosexuels
réponds je te replonge jamais on t'a
jamais proposé les choses
tu plais un peu au [ __ ] quand même
et les [ __ ] tu connais ah non non
jamais tu as jamais été au bruit mais
jamais j'ai jamais monté avec une pub
juste pour regarder une fois
combien tu as payé oh c'était il y a
longtemps 50 francs
c'est combien c'est maintenant non je
sais pas tu sais pas tu sais sûrement
ouais t'en fais pas qu'on sait allez
c'est nous qu'on pose des questions ici
ça te dégoûte ou quoi
non ça me dégoûte pas j'adore les femmes
bah alors pourquoi tu vas pas plus
souvent parce que j'ai pas d'argent toi
pour l'argent du poivre
si tu continues
sur la table de la cuisine
sur la table de la cuisine dans un lit
tu préfères les lits j'aime bien le
confort et la moquette aussi
dans Paris partout avec elle bravo et le
point G tu y crois oui oui je l'ai
trouvé tu l'as trouvé que les rencontrer
je peux vous en parler alors parlez-en
tu es là pour ça et ben oui c'est un
point qu'on trouve comme ça et on sent
les réactions alors c'est le point G
quand ça part en arrière c'est que c'est
le point G tu la connais bien maman à
ton avis elle est plutôt vaginale ou
plutôt ridienne de maman tu as fiancée à
maman tirage
ah ah les ordures il est juste
de la police
elle adore ça elle adore ça c'est toi
aussi hein
dis-moi Simone
un grand [ __ ] comme toi
plus du tout depuis qu'elle a acheté
depuis que je suis amoureux depuis quoi
je suis amoureux c'est un mot que tu
connais pas ça fait combien de temps
elle fait la petite lessive depuis 5 ans
c'est Pascal qui se masturbe c'est plus
doux qui va sortir
tout va bien
ils sont de quoi faire avec tout ce qui
nous a raconté
vos rapports c'est plutôt combien c'est
une fois par semaine une fois par jour
une fois par mois la fréquence en
moyenne
tous les deux jours une fois tous les
deux jours des fois tous les jours en
vacances une fois tous les deux jours ou
deux fois tous les deux jours on fait
plein d'émissions
à ton avis
des fois ça va chercher dans les mineurs
et c'est à côté combien ton petit
contrôle ça t'a coûté combien la
République là un petit rare justement
c'est-à-dire 30000 balles
c'est pas une grosse carrière il y a
c'est normal c'est pas une star tu
dépenses combien par mois
une brille de briques trois briques à
droite c'est bien ce que vous dépenses
3 ouais
il y a pas de panier à gauche la maison
par exemple là on a vu tantôt dis là
non non c'est en location tu payes
combien par exemple
5000 balles et tu as quoi comme frère
mais comme toi ah bah moi je voyage
beaucoup maman
tu as une bonne c'est un homme ou une
femme c'est une femme c'est une femme
elle s'appelle comment quoi la bonne
elle s'appelle Yvonne even Simone et
Yvonne d'accord ça va ça va être avec un
peu elle a eu combien de Mike tapé avant
toi je sais pas mais sauter combien de
fois avant toi
et plouf c'est fini prochaine descente
de police la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
le plus pervers
qu'il ne fait pas bon tomber entre les
griffes des deux imper de descente de
police leur victime cette semaine c'est
Michel Boujenah homme de café-théâtre
comédien on peut le voir actuellement
dans le film trois hommes dans un
couffin et il sera du 4 au 8 décembre
prochain à l'Olympia
[Musique]
je suis français
prénom c'est quoi Michel et d'autres tu
en as d'autres des prénoms non j'ai que
Michel
qu'est-ce qu'elle écrit non j'ai que
voilà ça devient précis tu vois des
questions
quoi tes parents sont juifs tunisiens
mes parents ma mère mon père est juste
une idée à ma mère elle est juif
algérienne c'est pour mieux vrai
d'accord ta date de naissance
3 11 52 ça fait quoi ça ça fait 32 ans
32 ans parce que si j'attends que vous
comptez oN EST DANS LA MERDE ton lieu de
naissance c'est Tunis
en Tunisie et c'était français en 52
encore c'était français non oui bien sûr
c'était français donc tu étais français
au départ mais non parce que les nous on
était tunisien on était pas oh c'est
trop compliqué c'est compliqué tu vas
recommencer là
tu étais plus français maintenant tu es
revenu français
voilà c'est ça en gros les pellicules
oui beaucoup c'est un problème
normalement
tu vas nous expliquer ce que c'est les
photos
quand même bleu
je sais plus mais c'est très tout de
suite après la naissance il y a 10 ans
15 ans
c'est au bout de trois semaines même pas
15 jours de la naissance
ouais ouais vraiment et ça
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une périphrase
par exemple une périphrase
avec une autre phrase la même chose que
dans l'autre bon qu'est-ce que c'est que
la gérontophilie par exemple
gérontophilie c'est pour les vieux un
style
aussi la même chose non si le J c'est
par exemple non par exemple les mecs qui
ont des impairs c'est des cons vous
emportez vous êtes vraiment de quoi
absolument pas la gueule
la gueule par exemple et l'armée tu l'as
fait avec Monsieur Diane où il y a sert
Arafat tu as pas fait l'armée
en France Tunisie au Maroc en France en
France
pourquoi même pas envie de faire l'armée
mais parce que tu me vois moi avec un
fusils de l'armée
j'étais mais non je ben j'ai dit j'ai
dit oui
on est là pour ça vas-y allez accouche
vous savez vous avez de la chance que je
sois blessé parce que sinon je te jure
toi tu passes un mauvais quart d'heure
je te jure on va se méfier maintenant et
alors
vas-y parle
pourquoi tu as pas fait l'armée l'armée
j'ai pas fait l'armée parce que je leur
ai dit que j'avais du travail comme
acteur et que ce qui est foutait à
l'armée je serai au chômage en sortant
et il allait [ __ ] ma carrière et alors
ils t'ont cru ouais c'était pas vrai
c'était pas vrai notamment anti- à
l'armée française
j'aime pas le jeu j'aime pas j'aime pas
vraiment français c'est pas un vice donc
ça tu le dis pas j'aime les femmes mais
c'est pas un vice non c'est pas vraiment
un vice non avec la gueule que tu as je
vais venir
[Musique]
les cigarettes d'abord
des cigarettes américaines quelle marque
combien combien de cigarettes
par jour des quoi des Marlboro
oui j'avais la fumée
pas plus je peux pas fumer plus
tard j'en ai fumer
mais j'ai pas honte de le dire ça m'est
arrivé de fumer les pétards alors
ça te fait rêver ça te fait quoi ça te
fait plein de choses
tu as le droit de vote
tu es plutôt socialiste pendant ce
communiste quand même
de gauche
c'est pas ça ils sont écoutés
avec tes beaux yeux là tu as dû avoir
pas mal de proposition de [ __ ] non mais
arrête arrêtez avec vos questions
j'ai pas envie de répondre
je vais te montrer moi
tu vas répondre ouais
je vais répondre
et quand tu baisses tu éteins la lumière
pas toujours pas toujours tu passes si
toi sur la table de la cuisine ou dans
la salle de bain non plus il y a pas de
règles
or vous aurez vraiment envie
ça va passer vraiment à la télé
je trouve qu'une femme je trouve que le
sang d'une femme c'est pas sale ah bon
non donc tu baisses des filles qu'on
leur règle mais vous ça
m'est arrivé j'ai une femme que j'aime
quand j'aime une voix
je vous le dirai pas c'était pour les
elle quel effet ça leur a fait je vous
le dire j'ai essayé
c'était pour lui faire plaisir pour te
faire plaisir
non mais ça m'est arrivé oui j'ai pas
honte de le dire
[Musique]
j'étais vraiment mal parce que j'avais
honte et la deuxième fois tu t'es dit
c'est comme la première fois
culpabiliser avec quoi
comme ça qu'est-ce que tu fais tu lui
dis je suis désolé camarade je monte pas
c'est du rigoles tu penses de ton
arrivée la première fois
qui c'est ton acteur préféré au cinéma
Charlie Chaplin qui sont vivants et on
parle pas des cadavres Dustin
Nicole sonne est en France on te dit en
France j'aime beaucoup
clusé je trouve que c'est un grand
acteur usé
Charlie Chaplin
qui t'aime pas là
qui j'aime pas attends
qui j'aime pas j'aime pas par exemple
tout le cirque Sophie Marceau j'aime pas
Sophie mars il va payer la Poste à peu
près
20 20 ou 25 millions 25 millions
mon gros ça va
je te jure je sais pas normalement c'est
pas c'est bien toi qui remplit ta
feuille d'impôts c'est Marouane
c'est les grands remplacer ta mère non
mais c'est son boulot chacun son travail
c'est combien pour
une amie
pour une soirée c'est combien on bouge
une arabe pour une soirée c'est combien
on veut t'inviter pour l'anniversaire de
la petite par exemple ça coûte combien
faut que tu viennes faire le pitre à la
maison
j'ai jamais fait tu as arrêté de faire
les animaux j'ai j'ai toujours joué au
théâtre c'est toujours bouteille au
moins 30 personnes comme tu veux jamais
un anniversaire
je sais pas je crois qu'il doit me
rester pour
vous
10000 francs ancien ouais pas
représentation en France non
une brique quoi ah et tu as perdu
sida c'est un drame bon qu'est-ce que tu
veux faire
tu peux faire attention à comment je
sais pas on te demande comment tu fais
attention est-ce que tu mets des capotes
avec les filles
alors mamie déjà des capotes il nous l'a
dit tout à l'heure non une fois une
capote dans ta vie une fois une fois et
pourquoi tu comptes c'est moins agréable
quand tu as une capote pourquoi tu
trouves ça agréable quand tu as une
queue automatique
nous ce que ça fait de mettre des
capotes
c'est fini bravo et
merci très bien ça plaît aussi ta page
nocturne le retour des deux impairs la
semaine prochaine
un père masticle le plus mastoc
à l'intérieur le plus pervers je vous
offre également quelque chose avec lancé
Farid en voyant débarquer l'internation
et l'impervaire dans le petit bistrot de
la Goutte d'Or de l'eau pour les impairs
qu'ils avaient répondu mon cœur avant de
l'embarquer quoi qu'il a des aviateurs
le shoppel de chopelia l'AS du sac de
mur
c'est important il semblerait du gland
ouais on est là c'est que c'est
important c'est pas ton vrai nom
ça vient d'où je te dis choper là
tibétain
ça va être long
ma copine m'appelle bébé
nationalité française
c'est toujours drôle
un certain temps
28 ans
Ton père il faisait quoi
mon père j'ai pas connu et ta mère elle
est morte aussi ma mère
a été viré non parce que
mon beau-père il travaille en usine
aussi non
quel genre de restaurant
classe
il a été dans quel pays
quel pays te demande l'Algérie
et en politique tu dis juste à gauche à
droite tu dis pas de nom
c'est drôle ça
[Musique]
par exemple
deviner
j'ai pas dit ça ah bon
j'ai dit que le mot beurre le mouvement
beurre ça me pense que ça commençait à
me casser les pieds je préfère qu'on
dise arabe
kabyle enfin désigne les gens parlent en
ont le mot beurre j'aime pas c'est un
côté péjoratif que j'aime pas voilà
c'est parce qu'ils disent
ça c'est leur c'est leur opinion moi
j'aime pas le mot beurre si eux ils sont
revendiquent en disant je suis un beurre
je suis un petit beurre et tout ça moi
ça j'ai pas ça mais toi tu voudrais
qu'on t'appelle un petit quoi là moi je
suis parisien
[Musique]
ça te fait mal à la tête ça te fait quoi
au début ça me faisait rigoler
maintenant ça me stresse tu as couché
avec qui pour réussir
certainement pour nous
j'ai fait manœuvre dans les usines
emballeurs en balai des paquets des
trucs comme ça
et puis après qu'est-ce que tu as fait
d'autre
j'ai fait j'ai servi dans un restaurant
et des petits boulots
c'est tout ça suffit c'est déjà pas mal
non tu as fait ça quand même temps c'est
pas combien de temps je l'ai fait sur
plusieurs années de trois ans quand
j'étais dans ce groupe quoi parce que on
gagne pas notre vie avec ce qu'on
faisait j'ai fait de la rue aussi j'ai
fait la manche dans la rue ouais
cette année tu as gagné combien ça
dépend si le film si je suis
qui s'enroule important pas quoi ça
dépend des jours de tournage 250
000 francs de tournage
une présence un peu plus de 30 jours de
tournage c'est pas mal payé combien tu
as déclaré d'impôts
tes amis c'est qui c'est pas que ça à
[ __ ] Balasko
comme ça là
faut que je réfléchisse
[Musique]
la voisine de ma grand-mère madame
Mazaudier
et la première fois c'était qui la
première fille c'était qui
c'était un Gisors dans une boîte à
Gisors elle s'appelait
j'étais tout seul c'était mon premier
baiser tout seul là-bas c'est encore
mieux on a même pas fait l'amour c'était
simplement un baiser c'était mon premier
baiser la première fois que tu as fait
l'amour cet écran
et la première fois que tu as fait
je me souviens plus
tu es sorti avec combien de filles dans
ta vie
je suis pas un carrelage
comme ça
c'est ça que je te demande
ça tu te calmes
où est-ce que tu préfères faire l'amour
dans un lit elle parle nous de ta
fiancée maintenant qui sait et
maquilleuse elle est maquilleuse
je te demande quand est-ce que tu l'as
rencontré et où ça vous n'aimait pas le
savoir c'est ma vie privée c'est ça qui
nous intéresse mon pote justement c'est
ta vie privée
tu as déjà couché avec un mec jamais et
les mecs je te demande
ma poule
avec des mecs
j'étais petit je vais me faire violer
et chez les pépé qu'est-ce que tu
préfères les blanches les noirs ou les
jaunes
nos couleurs c'est n'importe quoi belle
la tienne elle est blanche là en ce
moment
avec une jaune oui
beaucoup de Français
tu accepterais de coucher avec un mec
pour un film
non j'accepterai pas exactement
j'ai pris une décision je vais pas
montrer mon cul au cinéma ah bon je
trouve que c'est pas nécessaire on peut
montrer ça autrement je veux dire je
suis violé c'est plus fort tu as des
principes j'ai pas des principes donc
j'ai conduit tout le monde voit mon cul
et sur les tournages tu as les aventures
avec les pépé non non c'était jamais
arrivé ça m'est jamais arrivé j'avais pu
passer ça
jamais essayé j'ai jamais essayé tu es
impuissant
si tu veux ça peut te faire plaisir ça
me fait plaisir ça me fait plaisir je te
le dis tout de suite après qu'est-ce que
tu vas faire en sortant d'ici imagine
que tu sors cet après-midi par exemple
pourrir une supposition tu sais en libre
qu'est-ce que tu fais
la première chose que je vais faire dans
le sortir par exemple
en français ça s'appelle comment
c'est encore secret le titre tu le
connais le morceau
je vous ai dit que j'ai travaillé dessus
il va sortir quand ce disque donc
c'est précis tout ça ça a l'air
intéressant au niveau cinéma
je vous ai dit que le projet qui me
tenait la course
écrase parce que sinon ça va mal se
passer
[Musique]
prochaine descente de police la semaine
prochaine sur TF1
pour être sûr de ne rien
rallumer
un pouce bleu